today we are meeting to complete the
turning of the page and launch our
joint work for the implementation
of this agreement
today we have just held the first
meeting of the eu-cuba joint council
until now cuba has been one of the
few countries in the world without
contractual ties with the  european union
this despite the fact that the european union
is the first commercial partner of cuba the
first investor and its main
development partner there are little candles
of pride it is so important to be in the
direction of its blessing and union in cuba
historically
the current state of  The European Union
' Cuba relations demonstrate the capacity to
build spaces for dialogue and
cooperation for mutual benefit and the
purpose of privileging the elements
that unite us over those that
differentiate us. Indeed, we have agreed to
hold five important
sectoral dialogues such as  are the
disarmament and non-proliferation of weapons of
mass destruction the illicit
arms trade  small and light weapons and other
conventional weapons unilateral coercive measures
human rights and the
2030 agenda for sustainable development
shows the good state of
cooperation between the european union and
cuba is the signing of the first
financing agreement for a renewable energy project
and  energy efficiency